Bruce Pearl the Auburn head coach in the
Continental Tire Coaches Corner
you're dressing like a coach today you
got your shorts on like it's a little
breezy here coach
I grew up in Boston so this is warm for
me but no that's what a beautiful set
you guys got here and a great crowd yeah
congratulations to those teams that are
here playing for the Final Four how do
you lose a recruit given how passionate
you are
how do you lose a recruit how do I lose
other guys are trying to yeah you know I
mean but you have an infectious
personality when you go in the room you
know Bruce pearls in the room I want to
be an energy gain not an energy drain I
want to be somebody that my coaches and
players want to be around I want them to
think that if they could be with me for
a period of time that they got a chance
to get better because I'm gonna
challenge them you know I'm not I'm not
gonna accept mediocrity I'm gonna see
something in them that they don't see
themselves that I'm going to work every
day to try to get them to to realize
their goals and dreams who's the guy you
lost that made you cry oh gosh oh you
know Jay Bilas my first job at Stanford
I called Jay Bilas I did I called Jay
Bilas he laughed at me he did he was
already committed to Duke but hadn't
signed and he was my first recruiting
call and I got shut down how about that
I didn't cry what about as a head coach
did who's the guy that you thought you
had like great one Quin Snyder okay he
went to Duke - he went sit there - yeah
Mercer Island Washington phenomenal
family great high school coach and and
actually he cried when he told me
because we were that close
oh well and - Quinn's credit we stayed
in touch and he even invited me to his
wedding and so you know there you got a
you got a win with dignity you gotta
lose graciously and I I didn't want to
make that a difficult call for Quinn
because I knew how difficult it was
gonna be to tell me no SEC basketball
try to explain that because it's known
for football but how do you
I did ask this question Frank Martin
yesterday if if you everybody got into
the Octagon all the coaches Frank
Martin's a one-seed in the Octagon right
no doubt so so who is coming out of the
who's last man standing all the SEC
coaches now he said Avery Johnson he
would be concerned about quick small he
wasn't worried about you coach I might
hurt somebody but accidentally
accidentally you know so we always
apologize for SEC basketball and what
makes SCC football what it is its speed
its athleticism its quickness its the
defensive linemen when the SEC lines up
in football everybody's afraid of that
well the same thing is true in
basketball we're a very athletic league
our teams play great defense and and you
know what we had eight teams in the NCAA
tournament this year so I do think SEC
basketball is back in Frank Martin
helped get it started last year by by
taking his team to the Final Four
yeah handicap this Final Four start with
Villanova and Kansas which is the
marquee matchup although I think
everybody is waiting for Loyola in
Michigan the Cinderella story this this
has been a great tournament and anything
is gone that the two favorites the two
one seeds villain over in Kansas
I think Villanova's got the best talent
and in this field I don't think these
are the best four teams in the country
but these are the best four coached
teams in the country these coaches have
done the best job with their group of
any anybody else in this field it's
small ball it's small ball is winning
right now nobody's got as Jay said
nobody's got that dominating post player
he actually Jay said something
interesting he thought it was going to
be that that size could have overwhelmed
a little a team I actually think a
little teams are better playing against
teams that had that size that can't
match up with five players that can all
shoot Pass and drive and he's right they
do have a chance to advance
I like Villanova to win it all I I think
they're they're built to be able to play
big or small and everybody is rooting
for Lola because they are such an
underdog in such a great story which the
one story that you love to tell when you
do banquets after-dinner speeches what's
the one that brings down the house I
don't know if there's a is a particular
story but for me it's about hard work
like hard work won't guarantee you
success but without hard work I
guarantee you won't ever success and
it's your choice what do you choose you
know that's the one thing that we could
control and and so it's not really a
story it just it's just a you know it's
a belief system and what's your favorite
story you tell no man man you got a
sense of humor and you got a treasure
trove of stories there coach I don't
know that I don't know that any of them
are really any or that funny you ever
how often do you talk about the Boston
College the point-shaving scandal
it just happens realize a freshman
Boston College when it when it went down
just so people know this is Henry Hill
this is the mob late 70s I believe 1978
okay so you're you're a student I'm a
student at Boston College I'm a manager
and I'm you know I'm witnessed to kind
of what's going on and you never what a
dream was going on guys just had a bad
night
you'll Rick Kuhn was the guy that was
you know the kind of the kingpin but he
wasn't a good enough player to be able
to affect the outcome of the game so
what what the stands the story goes he
got Jim Sweeney to jump in and try to
help him and Jim was the point guard Jim
Sweeney was it was as good a player as
good as student athlete as good a guy as
there was on campus he was the best and
affected you know he got into something
like that sir it was very very
unpredictable but he could affect the
games to the point where they were
getting it all done and then you know
whether it whether it's whether it's
spread to other guys on a team you just
don't know but there were times you were
like you couldn't believe how they were
playing so when you look back anyway
there something wasn't right
do you remember the day you found out
that they were fixing games I don't but
I but I was floored I had no idea
absolutely no idea it would have made no
sense until you look back any what that
game he didn't even shoot the ball that
game but you have this now that the
movie Goodfellas that's those are the
characters that are involved in you know
the real-life characters are involved in
this point shaving scandal
this is real are you surprised it hasn't
happened more often because of cases
like that we do as good a job as we
possibly can of getting to the kids and
making sure they understand you're going
to be victims and and there's a lot of
talk right now about about the kids are
being exploited and they are victims and
you know it's it's it's a great way to
obviously lose your eligibility but but
in real life you know those kids were
threatened their life you know they were
threatened if they didn't go and and see
this it just it's just not worth the
risk is not worth the reward he's Bruce
Pearl Auburn head coach joining his
countenance hire coaches corner Syracuse
loses a five-star recruit to the jeely
how strange is this well I think that if
we lose the the ability for the the
pathway to the NBA to go through the
college campuses we've really lost
something I could tell you back back at
years ago when there was proposition 48
remember where the academic rules
changed I was right there with John
Thompson and John Cheney saying you know
what it is gonna catch a group of
student athletes in such a way that's
not fair but but yeah and they were
right but guess what happened everybody
caught up parents were going into their
junior high schools and middle school
said listen my son is gonna be taking
algebra as a ninth grader he is going to
be a qualifier and so everybody kind of
caught up with the academic rules we're
better off with the college scholarships
intercollegiate scholarship has not as
much the diverse of our country's
anything and so I don't want kids in
eighth grade or ninth grade thinking
that they're all gonna go to the NBA
because they're not gonna take freshman
algebra and they're not gonna work to
get into college and even those those
guys are in college for one year or two
years they still got a home they could
still go back and I believe they're
better off for having gone into the
college game first yeah I'm okay with
the one-and-done
I would I would hope that if you want to
come out after high school then be able
to come out after high school you know
it's a risk for you it's a risk for the
NBA team and hopefully you know you have
kids who understand the value of college
and you know even if you accidentally
get a one-year education that's one more
than you were going to get but I don't
want to hold that against you if Diane
Williamson I would think
could come out right now and play what
do you say that's fair why they guard a
Barrett could I don't know whether I
could but I agree yes it's fair
yes very possibly and there's probably
one how many kids do you think current
high school seniors could play in the
NBA I would I would say fly safe from
last year I would say there are five
kids on average every year that
potentially come out but Dan here's the
problem if five kids think they can come
out try to come out that's what the
problem look I agree with you that if
they're good enough you shouldn't you
should be able to go and and you know
you remember when BAM Adebayo
and those guys lost on the way to the
Final Four a year ago and those kids
were the locker room in tears yeah okay
they they cared they would they wanted
to get to the Final Four were national
champs it for Kentucky those kids are
forever gonna be caught up Kentucky
basketball history
and when Bam's done playing with the
Miami Heat or in summary he's gonna go
back and finish his degree and I just
think that's a really really good thing
so look the system's not broken it's
there's still so much more good about
what we do than bad we could indeed need
a few tweaks we now have a realistic
scholarship remember back in the day you
used to get laundry money yeah do you
get learning but in Eastern Kentucky no
my roommate did but now because of the
Pell Grant and because of a true cost of
attendance we are now able to give our
kids a much more realistic scholarship
and and and and so we're going in the
right direction
I still have eligibility left really
now I'm gonna offer this to you so
one-time only offer God preseason
exhibition I suit up Robin continue
I mean what else trying to say okay yeah
what was your SAT was it four digits I
can get into Auburn let's put it that we
got into Auburn for God's so I could if
you would like to make an official offer
I'm open to putting Auburn basketball
back on the map if you want to focus on
your books and your body your basketball
on your Bible you come to Auburn you
come play for me and together we're
gonna win championships I like to focus
on my hair and my jumper okay in that
order
you'd fit in perfectly then I tell you
right now what if I just came and shot
layups like I got up and I got in the
layup like you're not to play me in a
preseason game there's no such thing as
a layup anymore I mean the only thing
you ever do with layup was isn't like
whoever sees a layup in the game you get
smashed to the floor if somebody comes
underneath you takes a charge or you
dunk on somebody's head no no when we're
just you know we're out there the team
we're on the layup line we're did if you
want to come to Auburn and going layup
lines for a preseason game it's a done
deal
Pauley who's on the phone Danny Avery
Johnson offer oh oh I got Avery Johnson
favori Johnson wants to know if I would
like to replace Collin Sexton at Alabama
now I'm like look don't there's no
pressure if you if you'd like to you'd
like to take advantage of this
opportunity here I'm coachable I play
hard play hurt good beer drinker like I
got it all I'm a five-tool player
how many hasn't called a tool how many
years of eligibility do you have left I
are you gonna be a would I would be a
one and done for Auburn like one night
and that's it
one night had done coach it's great to
see you Congrats on the success there at
Auburn he's a Bruce Pearl Continental
Tire Coaches Corner
I have a commercial read for the
Continental Tire coaches corner here so
sit there and act like you're enthused
okay Bruce Pearl Continental Tire
coaches corner whether you're a student
as I could be alumni or an all-around
fan Continental Tire has a tire that can
get you to the big game they are a proud
supporter of thirty-two college
basketball teams across the United
States you can let them know your
passion for basketball the ode to
basketball for more information visit
Continental Tire dot-com for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]